so I'm Mira Cena I grew up in Armenia
and you also have some Armenian roots
and chess in Armenia is just so big even
as a child now of course they want so
many Olympians Levon Aronian has been
number two in the world for as long as I
can remember until recently and can you
tell us a little something about your
childhood
yes actually I was born in Moldova but
my mom is Armenian and she played for
their minyan team so I've spent a lot of
summers and a lot of time in their mania
and what struck me most even when I was
a child is the chess it is really a part
of other cultures so when you would go
in the streets everyone would play chess
and the gamin well I have to actually I
I loved both so that's well I picked up
the game with my parents of course my
mom is is a women's Grandmaster as well
so she played a lot of her limpets and
also she she's a chess teacher so she
dedicated her life to well teaching
chess to kids and that's actually how I
grew up you know I was sitting there the
chess club even though I really didn't
know like what to do with those pieces
you know they were absolutely magical to
me and then for example when I would go
back to Armenia aware Georgia I would
always play you know like some strange
games and then I would see people on the
streets you know playing against each
other and then like I said okay I want
to do this myself yeah the way I learned
chess was accidentally I was at my dad's
fourth place and he was cleaning his
desk and I said the small chess set so I
just asked him what is this and he told
me how it's a Chesky it's a game and
then he thought the best way for me to
learn is to watch him play with his
friends I just learned by watching him
play but it was so easy for me to get
into it soon after I went to coaching
and of course started playing I learned
when I was eight started playing in
tournaments when I was nine when the
Armenian US Championship and then
qualified for world youth and it just
took for me the culture in Armenia is so
different because as you said like
everyone plays chess
it's so hard to find you know a family
where someone doesn't play chess and I
also feel the big difference is the main
emphasis is to become a strong chess
player not not to just learn chess to
have you know to have fun or do some
activity maybe it has changed now
because they have chess in the schools
Armenia is the only country that has
chess in the schools as a subject but
for me growing up chess was almost like
a job of course and I can understand
that especially with such a historical
figure like it's a grant address and
actually my mom played in the team with
him that was also very inspiring for me
and if we talk about for example chess
in Caucasus we can talk about Georgian
chess school and I think such historical
figure is like no no gap in - really and
my chipper needs to bird onions that
they contributed so much actually to
inspire the whole generation sometimes I
think that it's just a matter of chance
that they had such a champion like Na
Nog apprentice really and then a
plethora of chess players and chess
champions came out of it like my
chickadee needs an initially onion then
who is this you know clearly and so many
others so now alexandra they've played
so many matches as well and as we know
Georgian chess school is still very
strong and and the Jag needs a is
playing this tournament so she will
defend you know is the owner of our
region of our chess history yeah it's
amazing that as you said the tradition
continues and they have so many
grandmasters or women haughtiness really
like needs abuts yes really and I
believe their entire team is just
grandmasters and they correct me found
what they won third place in the
Olympiad last year yes and also when I
had to look at the lineup of this
tournament you know almost all of the
players are having Grandmaster title
only like I think one player she will
actually have a chance to to make a norm
in this trial ceremonia the sermon is
very impressive but going back to where
we came from so what would you say is
the difference between chess in Armenian
just in Moldova well the main difference
huh that's it's a very interesting
question because as a kid I really
didn't see it because there was also
such a passion for chess because at that
time it was of course part of the Soviet
Union and of the general chess was a
general element of our culture so Soviet
culture and which worship chess actually
so there was so much respect so
basically like I was playing chess in
Armenia in Moldova all over the Soviet
Union and actually as a kid it brought
me a lot of joy yeah but I also feel
like that when I was growing up and I
still lived there I mean it just didn't
have the same kind of support it does
now we didn't have the Federation didn't
pay for anything if we qualify to world
youth it was on each parent to find some
kind of money to send their kids to
these international championships I
remember in my first world youth when we
went to France we had like four people
on our team and like I was the only girl
because daughters couldn't find any
money and we had one coach and and then
I think we're renting an apartment
everyone was staying together and this
is one of my big differences when I came
to the US there were like so many
culture shocks for me but when I played
in World Youth like each kid had a
parent and it was just like journey to
go and represent your country and for us
it was you know whoever could find any
kind of money to send their kids and
that's what they did well it reminds me
of this product like there aspera Destry
no so even if the world is difficult you
were aiming for the stars so I think
that we lived through the same period
and it was actually very difficult
because our countries were undergoing
Cersei well such dramatic changes but I
think that no matter what you'd like we
all kept our love for chess and the
motivation actually to to participate in
all of these tournaments because I think
there's this I don't there's something
inside us that forces us to go on you
know
and I think that's part of also of our
culture human spirit that gives the guy
yeah I mean she's in Armenia has
actually improved somewhat right now
they got so much government sponsorships
and we had the chess house the thing I
was on house of course with the school
and they also got funding for a chess
Academy where the talented kids would go
to now they have chess in the schools
and I've actually looked through those
books they they look really challenging
and I talked to some other [ __ ] on
about it it's one of the founders being
the founder and he said that the main
point is to introduce logic and critical
thinking to children like the point of
it is not to create strong players which
is a little different from how I grew up
but now they're just introducing chess
everyone so maybe in the next generation
everyone in Armenia is going to be
playing chess well actually I I agree
with this point of view because just
develops not only logical reasoning but
critical thinking also to consider every
situation is unique I think it's very
important to be able to analyze things
and I think it's it only well makes us
stronger and better as individuals so
like we hopefully chess will be taught
in schools soon like everywhere I hope
so if if it will be taken but the same
kind of initiative has been taken up in
like in France so there are a lot of
schools and even sometimes the
universities which have chess as a
subject and you can even take it for
like as a subject for buckle area so I
think it's a very interesting approach
yeah there are some schools in the u.s.
who also do that but I think to do it in
the u.s. of the country maybe state by
state would be more reasonable and
district by district because you know
there's so many schools but growing up
in this chess culture what was it like
for you when you moved to friends Oh
at some point it was not easy because
when you are moving to another country
you have to assimilate with another
culture and also learn a new language
but
what struck me the most is like well
chess is just everywhere so I was not
alone so I was surrounded by friends so
French players are actually very
passionate so they I think they just I
don't even know like they healed the
void you know so I've never felt that it
was different
yeah and I think I had a similar thing
because when I moved to the u.s. I was
13 said there was a very difficult age
because I was a teenager and you know
that's such a hard age to make such a
big transition but also I also had chess
at least if I couldn't speak English I
couldn't do anything unless I had chess
and that really helped me through a
period